hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play oh okay
so I have no idea what I need to do I've
got a doll with a red eye that statue is
still plaguing me I don't know what to
do with it I'm thinking I was supposed
to send it downstairs
and just kind of crash into the place
but apparently that's not a thing and
that's not what I need to do so what I
got one joke a problem what the hell get
out of here man
oh oh oh oh no oh no oh no no hang
yourself fool hang yourself he didn't
hang himself
okay go away usually when I go into a
room and come back out of it he do that
was there something in that fireplace
that I needed there's a fireplace can i
light it light the fireplace yeah okay
that's kind of small but cozy I guess
this purple monsters can fit into pretty
small packages that's what Shh okay no
that's probably the best that's what she
said I've ever come across
okay hey anyway um but the ah ah what
happened what happened oh I got the red
stone out of it sigh cool I guess what
do I do with it that's cool that still
doesn't help me know what I'm supposed
to do I think maybe maybe what was
upstairs again I've totally forgotten
what was upstairs probably a monster
waiting to jump out of me ooh ooh
there's writing on the wall three six
one okay alright then I got three six
one okay alright thank you sir for the
code it seems to be missing a number
though but I guess I can play the
guessing game for the last one all right
I got something it's something it's not
a lot but it's something I've got a
redstone in a code still need to find
out what to do with this statue I'm
wondering if I can actually maybe it
wasn't supposed to go into this room
there we go okay so let me try this
again let me push it into the other room
and maybe it'll do something else hello
hello hello hello no no okay this was
wrong all right um I could have sworn I
could have sworn that what I was
supposed to do wait a minute something
looks different over there to the left
it looks like there's a crack in the
floor maybe that's it
it's hard to tell the detail because
everything's so duct damn it I thought
okay I thought I was wrong I apologize I
want to break this thing I think that's
the only way to do it but I don't know
where to go where the hell do I push
this thing where the hell maybe that
pattern on the floor over there oh come
on
there's a perfectly acceptable hole in
the ground right there I want to I want
to I know this is right I know it has to
be right it's gotta be right
ah okay I don't know what to do with
that whatever let's go down to the
basement what awaits us down here the
door is locked
maybe I could take it with a Phillips
head yeah that's it that's it okay no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no okay
so what we got here is a failure to
communicate there's also a hole over
here but I can't even get the statue
over this way there's got to be
something that I'm missing there just
has to be ah where'd you come from how
are they been doing anything I wasn't
doing anything hang yourself ooh
a ghost oh I wasn't doing anything
you just came in out of nowhere maybe
that's like a clue maybe I gotta push
the statue out of the door I didn't
think of that
oh I'm all the way back here oh maybe
that's a thing maybe I gotta push the
statue out through the front door and do
something about that maybe maybe maybe
that maybe that guy was a clue because
that guy's come out of places that I
need to go like the fireplace in the
closet and the thing thingy yeah yeah
yeah I made him fall he broke I got a
blue stone yeah all right okay all right
okay all right okay
oh I haven't burned you yet ain't gonna
gotta burn you oh that means the other
thing this is the thing ah ah nope you
didn't come out of the fireplace you
came out of the hole in the ground I'm
gonna go this way
I'm gonna go this way Dubey barn me
hiding oh yeah what now business oh yeah
don't look in the one closet in the room
what kind of idiot monster yeah right
you better go away okay Pete Mosely hmm
who's right here well there's a box over
there and a closet my brain and then
uncle dies with a head that big you
think you'd have a bigger brain but he
does not okay so what I need to do as
you near the burn this doll if that was
English and you could understand it
congratulations you know better than I
do light it light it up light it on fire
burn the dog get the eye then we go
we're ready to rock that took way too
long I should have realized that
beforehand but you know me you know me
guys
I experienced it for what it is I don't
predict so I got dolls I eyes I should
say there was one doll over here that
had no eyes so if I put the blues hi we
go enter to the blue so this one and
then put the red ah that's kind of
disturbing but whatever
found the item doll head what it kind of
looks like a doorknob to make any what
perfect am I gonna use it for come on
Hiroshi amuse your giant brain maybe
lose something over here maybe I could
just put the doll head in there please
please could that be a that can't be
that easy oh ah I knew it was impossible
I knew it
and I know the code to this three six
one oh yeah
basement key was he there the whole time
is that Turkey she oh man how was even
looking was he there the whole time
ah no he's blond he's blond 100 that's
friggin hilarious wait what happened
what happened what happened okay
this is weird the squared is weird this
is weird this is weird
what's going on this is weird what's
going on so many codes so many high-tech
stuff for an old mansion what's going on
I hear breathing
happen okay hey I didn't did that get
power to everything I found the item
picture book okay what's in the picture
book I got the blonde oh oh I can't read
this blue green red what I got something
I found the item bookmark good it's kind
of color-coded like what I saw over
there oh yay drained it again red key
for something's in the bathroom right
there
good good good good good good good got a
red key maybe I need all these
color-coded crap and everything's gone
pastel over here so I'm assuming the
colors are kind of important long as
blondie doesn't come over at me use a
red key nope
okie dokie it won't open
oh god no I need another key code I
don't know what to do though okay so I
got to think about this got a bookmark
that was inside the picture book blue
green white and red there's no real
coordination to it that I can tell
anyway but it seems hand-drawn okay so I
got that blondie has vacated the area
the blonde what stabber that's it that's
a good name I like that name what am I
going to do
where there dear oh dear there must be
something over here it's got to be to do
over here cuz this is just like the new
area this is a new place that I'm
supposed to be right right right right
and then there's that creepy breathing
down the back of my neck that I have no
idea what it is what is four or why it's
even here this game is getting freakier
but I'm getting lost here ah-ha move
everything that is the key oh no oh
oh no I had it ah I was right there can
I move this ah the one chair that I
can't move ah I got a limb
oh man I was right there Oh I use a red
key Azure thing ah maybe I could pick it
with the fry dad maybe I switch out for
the Phillips head yeah I'll do that
the Phillips head No damn it I was so
close I was thought ah I'm so close
all right I thought I had a stroke of
genius ere was about to get more excited
than I should have been again okay but
anyway let's carry on
alright so let me think about this for a
second here if there was if that was
that and then I go over there and I do
that thing that I was gonna do there
must be some Mouse
there's gotta be some else I've got a
red key was there any other door that
was locked that might need to be opened
that's the question
is there another door that was locked
over here cuz that whole area that I was
just in was kind of you know red maybe
there was I don't know I have no idea
what I'm doing this mansion is totally
boned is there anything I have a light
bulb ah I don't know trying to think I'm
trying to think here guys I'm trying to
use my brain but my brain is not up to
the task it was a light bulb where would
I use a light bulb well there's gotta be
something to this there's got to be
something to it's red green white and
blue it's like the bookmark it is
exactly like the bookmark so there's got
to be a way that I can use the bookmark
in this fashion I don't know the code
there's gotta be something that I'm
missing there is there's only this is
the new area ah blonde a blonde days
back plug it back oh no oh no yeah sacré
moons and blondie is gone Thank You
blondie go away okay anyway so he came
out of that other room that's what he
did he came out of that other room
that's probably leading me over there he
came out of this room there's got to be
something in here that I need got me
this plant is the only thing that's
colored maybe I can light it on fire
maybe I can shove a flight bulb up its
ass and get that it's gotta be got to be
something writing on the wall secret
hidden door secret something there's a
Phillips head screw there there's a
fella Brad it's a Philips head Booga oh
come on wait a minute the picture book
that looks like the faces in the picture
book and where's the picture book oh no
no the picture book anymore the cork ah
ah I mean what does that mean oh goes
red green white blue there's one red
green to green white blue ah oh man
okay I can't celebrate about that one
cuz that one took me way too long that
would be way too long in fact it ran me
right out of time so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
whoever it is it I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
and fun star
I got a key belonging to the climbing
just annoys to
I don't need to go there for you to tell
me what I need to do you're me